you must promise me that there's not
gonna be any drunk I promise I promise
look at me in my eyes and promise I
probably go dramas as your hey welcome
to your weekly ticket well it looks like
Michael Keaton is returning to play
Batman Keaton who famously starred as
the Caped Crusader in the Tim Burton
directed Batman movies is in talks to
return to the role for the Warner
Brothers DC Film Ezra Miller will star
as Barry Allen aka the flash and the
project will be directed by it filmmaker
Andy muschietti the movie is described
as a loose adaptation of Geoff Johns and
Andy Q Bert's flashpoint comic book
storyline the flash will reportedly
follow Ezra Miller's Barry Allen as he
travels back in time to prevent his
mother's death only to inadvertently
create an alternate timeline wherein the
present-day Keaton's Batman has been
guarding Gotham City for the past thirty
years I can't commit to anything that
long good job Batman also Christina
Hudson who will be writing the script
for the flash will be re teaming up with
Margot Robbie for an all-new Pirates of
the Caribbean movie Robbie is set to
star and Hudson will penned the new
female lead screenplay for Disney the
film is said to be an original story
with new characters that is inspired by
the long-running attraction at Disney
Parks this project is separate from the
already announced franchise reboot being
developed by pirate scribe Ted Elliott
and Chernobyl creator Craig Mazin and
Matthew a cherry will direct an original
comedy for Warner Brothers titled the
come-up the film will be written by Emmy
nominated writer from when they see us
Michael Starr Barry and is described as
Friday meets Ocean's eleven the original
idea comes from actor and comedian
Jermaine Fowler who will star and also
serve as an executive producer
larell Howry Keith Lucas and Kenneth
Lucas are all set to star in the film
and if you're looking for suggestions
for what to watch this week well look no
further because we have colliders own
Perry memmer off with a suggestion for
us what do you got oh I was so excited
to bring this one up because I would
recommend this for a multitude of
reasons I've got a feeling a lot of
people out there have seen Shawn Baker's
movie the Florida Project but the one
that I really want to recommend right
now is tangerine because I just really
think that's a game-changing film in so
many different ways so in case you need
a little background on this one movie
takes place Christmas Eve in Los Angeles
and it focuses on two transgender women
Cindy and Alexandra and it begins with
Cindy just getting out of jail and
Alexandra kind of accidentally slipping
and revealing that Cindy's pimp
boyfriend has been sleeping with someone
else so much of the movie focuses on
Cindy's kind of relentless determination
to run around the city and find this
woman and Kitana Kiki Rodriguez and Maya
Taylor are just they are electric in
these roles and so much of tangerine has
this kind of this madcap romp kind of
feel to it but it's also a really sweet
story of friendship and I feel like it's
their performances that let a movie like
this have that kind of effective
sincerity to it and I also have to throw
in why this movie made a lot of
headlines when it first came out and
it's the fact that it was shot entirely
on a modified iPhone and I know that Ken
sounds like a real cheesy gimmick but I
can assure you it's not and I found that
it was a technical choice that really
added more intimacy to the film and just
brings you closer to the character so
tangerine a must watch a fantastic film
and also a fantastic film that has
brought more visibility and still brings
more visibility to the transgender
community so seriously get on this one
cannot recommend it enough I would say
ending yes I've been absolutely looking
for something exactly like that to watch
so that's a great suggestion also cool
that there's like a technical point to
it so obviously
by their hands a cyber recommendation
for me today this I do I do you've
probably seen it some people haven't I
waited way too long
upgrade if you haven't seen upgrade
upgrade is bananas it took me forever to
see it I wanted to watch it before
Invisible Man and I did because it's the
same director Lee why now it's about a
man who gets paralyzed from a mugging
and then gets installed with a computer
system called stem he's able to walk
again but also he has supernatural
abilities he can fight like crazy if you
like John wick or you like black mirror
and or or you like both you're gonna
love this it's crazy I didn't know what
to expect because I didn't want to watch
any trailers and ya know it's it's
madness I loved it and I wish everyone
that likes any sort of action movie
would see it it's filmed normal it
doesn't stop well you do know that the
really cool technical thing that Leigh
Whannell is coming to be very well-known
for now is the motion control camera
that's part of the reason why his action
sequences are stand that you see an
Invisible Man and you see it all over
the place and upgrade and I feel like
that's just one of the many reasons why
he's gonna wind up being one of the
great Jean redirect errs we have oh
absolutely when they mentioned that he
might be in charge of the like monster
Cinematic Universe for universal I'm
like oh yeah just give it to him just
like to let him do whatever he wants you
know and he's gonna run with it too
because I believe news drop that they're
turning upgrade into a TV series so get
ready for more of that that's oh my god
thank you I forgot I was gonna mention
that yes it's it's also become a
television series so yeah I can't I
can't wait for that thank you so much
for joining us Perry make sure to check
out Collider as well thank you
available to watch at home on Friday
John Lewis good trouble using
present-day interviews with Lewis now
eighty years old
Porter explores his childhood
experiences his inspiring family and his
fateful meeting with dr. Martin Luther
King jr. in 1957 and also available to
watch at home on Friday the outpost do
you remember what happened when during
the battle a team of US soldiers
stationed at the deadliest outpost in
Afghanistan are relentlessly attacked by
an overwhelming force of Taliban
insurgents their fight for survival is
the ultimate display of American valor
the film which is based on true events
was directed by Rod Lawrie and stars
Orlando Bloom Scott Eastwood and Milo
Gibson
all right everyone well that's it for
today leave us a comment and let us know
if you'll be seeing the outpost or John
Lewis good trouble I'm Kayla Mata mess
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]